for the third successive day students in
various parts of Sudan raised their
voices calling for justice and
accountability and trials for the
soldiers who opened fire on fellow
students on Monday at least six were
killed and dozens injured in North Korea
Japan as they protested about the cost
of living
the protesters calls for justice are
repeated by the African Union the
African Union categorically denounces
the killing of students taking part in a
peaceful protest and offer our
condolences to the families of those who
lost their lives
we used the quick arrest of those
responsible for the killings and for
them to stand trial and face punishment
according to the laws in this country
Monday's shootings happened as
high-school students complained about
the lack of bread and the rising costs
of fuel and transport as students took
to the streets to mourn and voice their
anger as Monday's killings the military
council blamed the opposition for the
deaths and ordered the closure of
schools nationwide the opposition
coalition known as the forces of freedom
and change continues to negotiate with
the military junta to form a
transitional government it's aimed at
replacing the military rule in place
since longtime President Omar al-bashir
was ousted in April the Sudanese
Communist Party one of the opposition
parties which is part of the coalition
announced that it wouldn't participate
in talks to form a government we as a
party will not go down that path or play
a role in the transitional authority our
Communist Party takes the side of the
masses we will escalate the situation in
the streets and continue efforts to
achieve the hopes and aspirations of our
people to bring about radical change
most of the protests have been led by
the Sudanese professionals Association
it says the Communist Party's refusal to
participate won't halts negotiations and
called for more protests to pressure the
military to relinquish power since al
Bashir was toppled all the parties said
they would not participate in any of the
levels of the transitional authority so
the Communist Party is no different but
that does not mean that those parties
will not take part in a future
government
a civilian government has been the
demand of demonstrators ever since they
took to the streets in December now
they're also demanding just as an
accountability for the rising number of
protesters being killed while
campaigning for change Heba morgen al
Jazeera Addis Ababa Ethiopia